all right good morning everyone my name
is Rob Moore my name is Matt Davies and
we're principal consultants at ratify so
we're here today to talk to you about
contemporary authentication so
authentication is obviously a pretty hot
topic in the last couple of years
there's password breaches and every week
there's people getting hacked left right
and center there's a lot of examples of
people doing things in ways that could
definitely be improved so that's
something that we really want to talk to
you a bit about today but what we found
when we started researching some of this
stuff is that it's really really
difficult to understand exactly what's
going on every time you do any searching
for what how how anything works you come
up with pretty complicated spec
documents you come up with all symbols
on issues all sorts of crazy definitions
using all sorts of stuff that's that's
really really difficult to follow so one
of the things that we wanted to do
especially on a morning right after a
crazy boat cruise is come up with some
really really simple explanations of
what's going on and try to use some
consistent terminology so that it's
hopefully reasonably easy to follow so
we've broken this clock up into four
parts
we've got the Y of authentication why do
we even care about this stuff we've got
the what so some of the different
terminology that goes on some of the
difference by basic concepts that we
really need to be aware of we've got the
how so what are some of the different
protocols and standards that are
involved in some of this stuff and then
we're going to deep dive into one of
those standards in particular which is
called open ID Connect which we really
believe is one of the fundamentally
important ones could be across at the
moment because it's basically everywhere
cool so let's start with the why why are
we standing here talking to now if we
start by looking at a traditional
application model s pretty much
everything within the application is
within the bounds of a single
application right so you've got your you
know UI business logic data layer the UI
is going to take credentials from the
user pass it across the some sort of
authentication source and check the
credentials itself and then it will do
some sort of lookup to check or throws a
ssin cool so if we look at a more modern
application we're seeing today a couple
of different things the first thing that
we're seeing is that people are quite
often externalizing their identity off
somewhere else outside of their
application and that's really useful for
a couple of reasons the first
that it means we can really leverage
third-party single sign-on providers we
can use like for example a Google
Facebook so on and these guys has
invested a lot of time and money and
effort into coming up with really really
secure implementations of this stuff and
frankly there's some really really
clever people who come up with this
stuff and they make sure that it works
really really well and we get all of
that for free the second thing that we
get out of this is really easy single
sign-on so users just have to maintain
one identity they can go use it a bunch
of different places they don't have to
remember a bunch of different passwords
it creates a really good experience for
them so that's the first thing that
we're seeing the second thing that we're
seeing is that people are building
applications in quite different ways
nowadays they're coming up with
applications which are much more
distributed than they use micro so much
more distributed than they used to be in
the past and what we send tend to find
is that you use a lot of different api's
a lot of different services you might
not own these services and api's anymore
they might be owned by third parties and
so you can no longer trust just giving
them your users passwords you need some
secure way to pass around the identity
that's being used so it creates some
interesting challenges and this is what
we want to talk a little bit about today
and on how to solve now certainly these
in particular two things that we're
noticing change the dynamic of how you
perform authentication compared to what
we did traditionally but there's
something else is also really important
and it's pretty much epitomized by this
website so most of you probably know
about Troy hunt he runs this website
have a bento INSCOM I encourage everyone
to go there and put your email address
in but your friend's email input your
friends email address is in after the
talk of course and check out you know
whether or not you've been in a breach
but what this website makes abundantly
clear very quickly is there is a lot of
breach passwords out there millions and
millions of them but more than that this
isn't something that just happens a
couple of times a year this is literally
happening every other week and all you
need to do to see that is just say
follow Troy on Twitter and look at all
the free tips he talks about so often
it's frankly scary being a web developer
and seeing that now absolutely yeah this
is why this stuff is important
if your application doesn't take a
password it doesn't need to store it and
you can't breach it and you've
completely removed a whole set of risks
oh so that's why we're here talking to
about the stuff let's talk about what
modern authentication actually is we
find that there's a number of terms and
concepts that are kind of important to
understand to be able to kind of get the
whole picture so we're going to dive
into a few of these and hopefully try to
explain them the first one is the
difference between identity
authentication and authorization now
we've actually got a nice physical
example of this so say I'm going out on
a Saturday night I decide I want to go
to a pub or bar or something like that
and have a drink so I walk up to the
entrance and then there's a bouncer
let's say his name's Matt actually a
little bit imposing and what I do at
that point is I say hi Oh where's all my
that's whatever fun man shelter I'm
going to click her on them go all right
so I walk up and they say hi I'm wrong
there's nothing work unless you like
yeah anyway so hi I'm Rob that's my
identity now I could say anything I want
to him I could say hi I'm Jim or Bob or
or whatever he's not going to know that
I am in fact Rob until I prove myself
until I authenticate myself now in this
instance that means I give him my
driver's license and at that point I was
indicated myself he knows I am now Rob
proven my identity now at that point
he's still not going to let me in
because he needs to authorize me to make
sure that I'm allowed to come in at that
point he needs to in this instance check
my driver's license for my date of birth
oh thank you and check that I am in fact
over the age of 18 not actually sure you
are might be a bit of an old photo so
once these check that and check that I'm
over 18 I've been authenticated
authorised I'm allowed access to the
resource that I wanted to so maybe a
beer in this case cool
now this situation plays itself out in
pretty much every modern authentication
is doing very modern application that's
doing authentication so this is just a
physical example of it the other thing
that's incredibly important to
understand is something called
claims-based authentication this is the
underpinning of basically every modern
authentication protocol we find that is
likely I mean we got really confused
we're trying to figure out what the
media's and being developers the first
thing we turn to to try to figure out
what it was is of course we went to
Stack Overflow now this is pretty much
the simplest definition we've been able
to find on what claims based off is so
this guy says claims based
authentication is about defining who you
trust to give you accurate information
about identity and only ever using that
information provided but let's dive in a
little bit deeper and try to explain it
a bit better again we've got you got a
nice physical example first if you think
about the government and more
specifically the licensing department in
the government simply some sort of
interference here by the licensing
Department issues driving licenses like
in the example we just showed with the
bouncer this is actually a real world
example of claims based authentication
in this instance the driver's license is
the identity token or security token the
bits of information on the driver's
license like your name address date of
birth there the claim claims and claims
based oils is basically just properties
attached to your identity now in this
instance the government is the identity
provider if we go back to that
stackoverflow quote that's the thing
that you trust you trust that the
government can identify someone so you
trust information provided by the
government in this example the identity
sorry the licensing department is the
security oaken service that issues the
token now there's one other fundamental
piece that's missing from this that
makes up claims-based authentication
it's the most important part because if
you think about the instance where I
walk up to the bouncer and I give this
driver's license he needs to check it to
make sure that it's valid that it's
actually been issued by the government
although it is not going to trust it it
needs to make sure that it hasn't been
it's not a fake ID basically and that's
the act of token validation now in the
case of the physical example is all
these cool holographic logos and that
sort of thing
on the driver's license that you can
look at to make sure that it's it's real
in a electronic example all of this
plays out and all of the modern
protocols that we're going to be looking
at in this talk and for instance a token
validation is usually done as a
cryptographically signed hash so one of
the things that you might have noticed
if you've done a lot of research into
this stuff yourself is that there's a
lot of different terms out there to
basically describe the same thing you
can you can have names that mean all
sorts of things so one of the things
that we really want to do as a part of
this talk is try and use fairly
consistent terminology so when we refer
to a relying party we mean the
application that's actually trying to
perform authentication when we refer to
a user we mean the actual end user
that's trying to authenticate and when
we refer to an identity provider we mean
the source of truth the entity that's
actually validating whether or not an
identity is correct now if you if you
look into this a bit you might see that
there's all sorts of names for this
stuff and confusingly for example a
relying party in auth is called a client
but in open ID Connect which is based on
a loss it's called a relying party so
it's easier to get a bit tripped up a
user can kind of confusingly be called a
subject such a weird pretty that's
pretty weird one identity providers can
be called all sorts of things so this
can be a bit of a useful like reference
I guess but when you're looking into
this a bit absolutely feel free to print
this slide out and print it up on your
wall so when you're looking at the old
circuit like 2:00 a.m. and you're not
getting to confuse you know how much you
like doing that yeah so when you think
of traditional authentication you might
first think about password
authentication obviously the most common
one out there and when we say password
authentication what we mean is that the
user will directly provide their
password to the identity provider the to
the sorry to the relying party the
relying party will then pass that
password on to the identity provider and
verify it usually that's against like
it's some sort of like internal database
or something like that this is a pretty
common set up and it's a pretty big
problem for a couple of reasons the
first is that that password is now
shared across some kind
potentially like Network environment in
a couple of different places and could
be intercepted so we've got that
password in places it doesn't
necessarily need to be the second is
that this doesn't really support a
scenario where that relying party isn't
it isn't the owner of those passwords
and credentials because you don't
necessarily know how it's going to
handle them or what it's going to do
with it so um there's a couple of things
that we can do about this to try and
sort this out
cool spoiler alert so that's where
tokens come in right so we just talked
about tokens with claims based
authentication with the driver's license
example and it's actually two different
types of tokens so there's reference
tokens and self-contained tokens
reference tokens are basically just a
random string of you know numbers and
letters and whatever it is is just
essentially a look at the way that that
works is that the user will provide
their password directly to the identity
provider so that the relying party never
sees it the identity provider will then
issue a reference token to the user
which they will pass on to the relying
party and at that point the relying
party will exchange that with the
identity provider in return for that
users identity and claims now because
they've talked directly to the identity
provider where there's some trust they
know that they can trust those identity
and claims self-contained tokens are a
little bit different so again the user
passes that password or credentials
directly to the identity provider but in
return they get their self-contained
token so weird and that token actually
contains the identity and claim
information inside of it so when that
token is then passed on to the relying
party then the relying party has
everything that they need to do
authentication and authorization for
that user now there's that important
step of token validation that's missing
here as well we're like not clicking and
and that's so that the relying party can
make sure that the token hasn't been
tampered with so for instance the user
hasn't gone and added a claim saying
that they're an admin user or something
like that that way they relying party
can make sure that the token is as it
was issued from the identity provider
which of course it trusts and that's the
most important part of claims based off
as we said cool so something else that
we wanted to talk about a little
at this point is multi-factor
authentication and we've got a
definition up there but basically
multi-factor authentication if you
haven't come across it before is
essentially trying to use more than one
proof of proof of verification that the
user is who they say they are so
typically that by combining two
different things one of those things is
something that the user knows which is
usually like some kind of static
password something that the user has so
quite typically like a mobile phone or
some kind of device that you can't
really like a clone or duplicate and
lastly you can sometimes combine in
biometrics so that's like your
thumbprint or something like that and
multi-factor authentication is really
really important because it gives us
such such a guarantee that the user is
who they are as compared to just a
password which is really easily leaked
out and really easily reused where this
kind of started is common elite mobile
numbers commonly phones sort of evolved
from there into token so software and
hardware tokens which are essentially
just things that the user has which
generate tow tokens or codes according
to some predefined algorithm which the
server also knows about so it can
essentially verify that the user has the
same token that they should that's
evolved even further from here into
using machine learning to actually
analyze the user's network activity and
login patterns and location and things
like that to verify they are who they
say they are
which gives us even more certainty so
this is this is evolving very quickly
but it's becoming increasingly more
important to start taking advantage of
some of this stuff as opposed to just
using passwords and it's really easily
really easy software the service
providers make this super simple if
you're using for example Microsoft Azure
ad you can get all this multi-factor
authentication and the machine learning
side just out of the box and the user
just automatically gets to opt in and
take advantage of this so it's kind of
cool and it's pretty easy and not many
excuses left and not start taking
advantage of some of this stuff if you
want to know a bit more about that
machine learning stuff it's something
called risk-based multi-factor
authentication feel free to hit up our
CIO t14 he will talk your ear off about
it for like an hour and it is pretty
cool though yeah so we wanted to talk
jump now and talk a little bit about how
some of the spam
that are involved here we're going to
talk a little bit about token standards
and the actual authentication protocols
that are used but I guess it's really
important to note that standards are
super important here they give you a
huge interoperability out of the box if
you're relying part of your application
is talking to an identity provider that
follows some certain standard you can
just drop a library into your
application and instantly be guaranteed
that it's all just going to work and
that lets you take advantage of peer
review and think if things like that
we're really really clever people have
looked at this stuff and come up with
implementations that are really really
secure and you're at less risk of making
mistakes let's be honest these people
are like way smarter than oh yeah way
smarter than us and I guess like
following on from that point the
security it becomes a lot simpler in
this case because you're again taking
advantage of really large standards
bodies that have figured this stuff out
they're usually backed by organizations
with a lot of money and resources and
time who put a lot of effort into making
these things really solid so you get a
lot out of just using them so the first
thing that's worth talking about is
token format so we're going to talk
mainly about sam'l and JWT tokens
there's a few different token formats
out there but we're just going to mainly
focus on those two so let's start by
looking at somal tokens this is the
incredibly boring frankly definition of
what observable token is essentially it
just boils down to it's a standard it's
an XML format it has the ability to have
attributes so that you can have claim
information and it's cryptographically
secure this is what a sandwich auction
looks like pretty crazy it's just gross
it's ugly it's for both it's exactly
what you expect and always wanted from
XML but but but to be fair to the sam'l
token format standard it's been around
for a long time it's incredibly robust
and it has a lot of support so like 99%
of the time you don't have to know
anything about that you just pull in a
library and it kind of work so it's
actually pretty useful now to be even
varus's able to examine if you had a bit
of kind of syntax highlighting bit of
formatting get rid of some of the
craziest XML stuff in there then it
actually ends up being quite simple if
you look at it there's essentially a
header which has
a the the actual issuer that issued the
token and the signature so that you can
verify that it's intact it's got a
subject statement talking about who's
indicating it's got an authentication
statement talking about the properties
of the actual act of authenticating and
then it's got a bunch of attributes
which is that claim information that
we've been talking about so JWT so we've
got a definition up here for a JSON web
token but essentially JW tees are an
attempt to try and make this stuff a
little bit more compact try and make it
such that a real person who's looking at
this stuff can basically understand
what's getting transmitted back and
forth and and delve into it a bit their
JavaScript token so obviously you get
the advantage of really strong
interoperability with JavaScript but
also with just about every other
language out there so really really easy
to use and they start to get a lot
simpler than some more tokens did so
we've got an example Matt yeah don't
mess with us Matt that's not Jack you
said it was going to be Jason them right
are carrying those two that I'm only
half messing with you
so this is base 64 encoded so what we've
got here is a basics before encoded
header followed by a base64 encoded
payload followed by a hash of those two
things and if we perform some magic and
we base64 decode this stuff we get
something looks like this
so adjacent web token has a header in it
so that's going to start with type
equals JWT that's always going to be the
case that's going to be followed by a
hashing algorithm that can be RS 2 5 6
or HS 2 5 6 if it's RS 2 5 6 it means
its certificate based hashing so you'll
also get the thumbprint of that x.509
certificate that's being used followed
by that in the actual body of the token
itself you've got a number of fields
that are reserved we haven't put the
complete list up here by any means but
these fields are basically if they're in
the token you can be assured of what
they mean they're very well defined if
you've got followed by that a number of
public claims so these public claims are
also well defined but they're defined in
their separate registry they're defined
in the ia and a registry for JWT
if you see these you know what they mean
but you don't necessarily you they're
not necessarily locked down over
they can be changed and lastly we've got
a number of private claims these are
totally custom claims that you basically
make up so you can put whatever you want
here you just need to define their
meaning on both your relying party side
and on the identity provider side and
make sure that they agree on what they
mean and you're not going to get great
interoperability with other third party
services that you don't own by using
them but they can be pretty handy in
some situations a couple other things to
note here so you can see that there's a
whole bunch of these really cryptic
three-letter and lot of claimed names
which on first inspection is a little
bit confusing but the reason why they
did that was very deliberate the
definition on the last slide talked
about the fact that JW tees are meant to
be compact this is very deliberate to
make them smaller because they're
deliberately designed to be passed
around in HTTP headers so you kind of
want them to not be too big right and
that's actually also the reason why
their basic ste 4 encoded so there isn't
any weird characters in there don't mess
with patient repeats cool so now that
we've talked about token formats are
going to talk about authentication
protocols arguably these are even more
important to have standards for from
security point of view because the
protocols are determined like what
information gets passed around who will
indicates where these are the ones where
it's even more likely to have those
little security holes so for instance
for a period of time there people were
using OAuth 2 and actually had something
called an open redirect attack in there
so we've got a bit of a timeline as the
different authentication protocols it's
really not important to remember of what
all of these are exactly the important
thing to note is that we started in
around like early 2000s and these
protocols sam'l WS Federation came
around in an effort for organizations
trying to figure out okay we've got an
application we want that application to
talk to an application owned by some
other organization but we don't just
want to give them all our passwords we
need to do something smarter than that
so that was federation that was an
attempt to solve that problem they were
also trying to figure out it really
early days how do we do single sign-on
effectively how do we try and make sure
I users don't have to log into the ten
apps that we own as a part of our org so
that's what they were trying to do there
in the mid-2000s we had protocols like
open ID come along and open ID was
actually an attempt by the social
networks to try and figure out okay well
we've got a huge number of user
identities how do we like start
leveraging our brand a bit better and
getting developers to start using those
identities and and spread them out a bit
wider without compromising the security
of our users so they were trying to make
it a lot simpler for developers to
integrate this stuff in the hopes that
that would start pushing that out and
they were obviously pretty successful as
so what we see today so that was all
followed by I guess more modern
protocols like Open ID Connect which
we'll talk a bit about a bit more in a
bit in in a bit but basically open ID
connects was an attempt to start
simplifying this even further and really
learn a lot of lessons from the past
especially around filling in some of the
gaps that previous protocols didn't
really standardize very well so pretty
much every protocol on the last slide
follows this basic flow what will happen
is the relying party will generate a
redirect URL they'll send the user on
that URL and it will take them through
the identity provider at which point
they're going to authenticate and then
the identity provider will come up with
a response and a redirect URL back to
the relying party at which point it can
process that response pretty much every
protocol follows this basic flow so what
we're going to look at is just a couple
of the protocols we saw in the last
slide to give an example in particular
of this first redirect URL this is what
WS Federation looks like especially not
too complex it's got an instruction to
the server in this case assigning one
pointer it's got this WT realm parameter
I don't know why it's called that but
that basically identifies the relying
party and as part of the registration
the relying party has with WS Federation
server then the server will know where
to redirect them back to we've also got
some context information which is just
transparent information that's passed
back on that redirect back to the
relying party WS Federation uses sam'l
tokens as its token format now
confusingly similar is not only a token
format but also an authentication
protocol and much like the token format
the I mean look at that URL that's just
nasty right the reason why it's so crazy
is that the request itself is a
a 64 encoded sam'l token and then the
whole request gets signed bit weird but
it means that this bi-directional trust
between the relying party and the
identity provider so it's incredibly row
buttoned and like I said earlier it's
got a lot of support if you are trying
to integrate some sort of off-the-shelf
or software as a service provider with
your corporate identity nine times out
of ten you're probably going to be using
sam'l to do it so it's a very powerful
and well supported standard and then
that leads us to a bit more of a modern
protocol in order to this is much nicer
and cleaner it's got an instruction
again to the server in this case
response type we've got a client ID
which identifies the relying party and
in this case we've a she also got a
redirect URI where the user should be
sent to after they authenticate that's
actually the source of that open
redirect bug that I mentioned if the
server doesn't verify that that redirect
URI is like ok in a whitelist then
you're kind of in a world of hurt call
so that leads us to open ID Connect so
one of the really interesting things
about OAuth 2 is it was actually just an
authorization protocol it was never an
authentication protocol but that doesn't
mean that people didn't use it as an
authentication protocol they all just
implemented it in slightly different
ways so Facebook Google Microsoft it all
had slightly different ways of doing
this originally so what Open ID Connect
attempts to do is fill in the gaps it
actually standardizes authentication as
well it uses JW tees as the token type
it supports multiple different relying
party types so you can use what web app
seeking use desktop app server the
server use JavaScript running on a web
browser which is pretty cool you can so
there's there's a whole heap of
different um client types there
depending on your implementation of open
ID Connect there's a whole heap of other
different things that it can provide you
can get token encryption you can
dynamically register your clients so you
don't actually have to configure them
all in the app they can register
themselves if that's what you want you
can do dynamic discovery of all of the
information about the open ID connect
server by your client relying party
application just dynamically which we'll
talk about a bit more in a bit
dynamic session management there's all
sorts of really really cool and useful
features that simplify the whole
experience the developers as part of
this cool so now that we've covered the
kind of basics behind token formats and
and authentication protocols as we said
we wanted to do a deep dive specifically
into open ID connect because it's
becoming increasingly prevalent and
important and in our mind is probably
the most important protocol to have some
understanding of these days so so what
we're going to do is break this up into
a few parts because I mean we are
talking it is very simple specification
but it's still a spec right so we're
going to try to break it in easy for you
because I mean frankly when we learn is
stuff like it melts at our brain so
first we're going to talk about some
fundamentals these are things that you
really need to understand in order to
kind of get what's going on in the rest
of the protocol starting with relying
parties now as Matt mentioned before one
of the things that overnight in connect
that just confuses me is that it's
literally an extension of oauth2 but it
uses a different word for the relying
party in the spec just really weird but
one of the important things to think
about with relying parties is
registration this is important from two
perspectives the relying party itself
needs to have some information about the
identity provider that it's talking to
so it needs to know for instance the
public key of the certificate that's
being used to sign the JWT so it can do
token validation and need to know a
bunch of URLs so it knows how and where
to talk to that identity provider and
then on the other side of things the
identity provider itself also needs to
know about the relying party so that
when it gets a request from that relying
party it knows that it can trusted it's
not some random app trying to hack in in
terms of the responsibility of a relying
party in open ad Connect it's basically
very simple it comes down to that basic
flow that we looked at before the
relying party needs about a constructor
request send the user on its way and
then deal with a response that comes
back from the open ad connect server in
terms of dealing with the response it
needs to be able to verify the signature
of any tokens in that response and look
at the timestamp and the last time of
those tokens to make sure that they're
still valid and they haven't expired
they're identified by a client ID
again confusing right it's called a
client ID but it's a relying party it's
just crazy anyway there's two types of
relying parties is confidential relying
parties and public relying parties
confidential relying parties can keep a
secret so typically it's something
running on a server whereas public
relying parties can't so typically
that's going to be either JavaScript
running in a web browser or it's going
to be a mobile application but it's
support space so one of the really
really cool things that Open ID Connect
mandates is that you put up a metadata
in point about your open ID Connect
service so you put that up at well -
known flash open ID - configuration that
contains all of the information that
you're relying parties possibly need to
know in order to authenticate to your
server so that's things like all of the
different API endpoints that you can hit
for different information the public key
of your finding certificate the
different like token types and claim
types and scopes that you support etc so
this lets us do some really cool things
that we previously haven't really been
able to do easily we can for example we
could change the finding certificate
that we use for our server and one of
the things that the spec mandates is
that you only cache that information
from this metadata endpoint for a
certain amount of time which means that
we can change the certificate and we can
guarantee that all of our clients can go
update against that new signing
certificate within a certain amount of
time previously that's something that's
been quite difficult you don't
necessarily own all the different
relying parties subscribing to you so
it's kind of cool when it gives us a lot
of power and flexibility one of the
things I think is probably the most
exciting bit about low commodity Connect
for me can be summarized by this bit of
code all you need to do to use Open ID
Connect at the bare minimum is something
like this you need one URL to the
identity provider server that's it you
pull in the library you pass it the URL
it goes to that endpoint
it figures everything out and you're
good to go that is just create a
convenient and this is this is obviously
c-sharp and Island but there's examples
for basically every programming language
out there and they all look something
like this at their simplest just one URL
cool so the next thing to talk about a
skirt now for those of you familiar with
OAuth 2 it's exactly the same as in
OAuth 2
so scopes allow you to tailor
authorization in order for me to try to
explain what that means I'll use an
example say that you've got some sort of
application X Y Z over here that's
trying to get you to log in to your
Twitter account by that application and
then it asks for permission to read your
tweets and also read your direct
messages now there's two types of scopes
is required and optional so the
application over here can say hey you
know what for me to be able to function
my core functionality is that I can read
your tweets if you don't grant me that
just don't bother but direct messages
there's this kind of sidebar kind of
cool nice to have functionality you know
we if you don't give me that I will just
adapt and hide that bit of the app what
this would look like in the UI is that
it'll be like hi login with your Twitter
account to application XYZ you will be
by doing this you will be granting
application XYZ the ability to read your
tweets and check box read your direct
messages and you can basically tick or
untick that checkbox depending on
whether or not you want to grab that
permission that active ticking or on
ticking is called consent basically how
it works the one thing that's kind of
different in open ad connectives open ID
Connect actually defines a set of
standard scopes and then obviously you
can also use whatever custom ones that
you want as well the standard scopes of
this list here the one at the top open
ID is required if you're using Open ID
connect to a Center cater user you have
to request the open ID scopes just part
of the spec the four scopes underneath
that will grant you a subset of
information about that user and we'll
look at with what the subsets are in a
bit the last one is kind of interesting
I've line access if you request the
offline access scope and it's granted
then you will be able to generate
something called refresh tokens and
we'll explain what they are in a second
so these are the these are the four main
tokens you get out of open ID Connect
you get an ID token so this is just the
user's identity and fairly
self-explanatory this is the JWT we were
talking about before and we've got an
access to
a concern access token is just a
representation of the fact that you've
got permission to access something on
behalf of a user also a JWT now you can
also have something called a refresh
token so refresh tokens basically just
the ability to get another access token
when yours expires and you might want to
do that in certain types of applications
and the last type of token is a code and
this is just a short-lived code that you
can exchange for a token in certain
types of scenarios which we'll cover a
little bit later terms and scenarios
where you might want to use refresh
tokens typically boiled down to two
scenarios one would be where say you're
in like a JavaScript running on a web
browser it's a public relying party so
the tokens are like visible there now
from a security perspective that means
that there's a higher likelihood those
tokens might be compromised which means
you probably want to shorten the
lifetime of them but what you can then
do is have the access tokens the shorter
lifetime and then have a refresh token
with a longer lifetime that you can use
to get new access tokens whenever you
need them cool so this is what an open
ID connects JWT looks like one of the
first things to point out here is that
unlike in regular JWT s there are
actually required fields here that you
do have to specify so we've got the
required ones up here those required
ones are basically just well defined
fields which always will have to be in
the token if you see them you know
exactly what they mean you've got some
optional fields here as well which are
just next on here those optional fields
again they're well defined if you see
them in your token you can be assured of
what they mean but you don't have to
specify these and then that's all
followed by a number of custom claims as
well and these custom ones are basically
again you can make these up you can do
whatever you want with these but you're
just then limited in your
interoperability and you just have to
specify exactly what they mean yourself
cool so now recover the fundamentals the
next thing to talk about is endpoints
it's a number of different endpoints
that you can communicate with with open
either connect these three here are the
required endpoints they will be in every
implementation of open IV connect server
there are also a bunch
other optional ones that we're not going
to cover the first endpoint to talk
about is the authorization endpoint this
is the endpoint that you send users to
to log in this endpoint will give the
users some sort of UI for them to
provide their credentials
now the endpoint will either return a
code or an ID token access token and or
refresh token depending on which flow
you use and we'll cover that in a little
bit
the initial redirect that the relying
party sends the user on to the identity
provider will look something like this
you'll have whatever the URL is for the
authorized endpoint and then there's
four required parameters there's a
response type client ID redirect URI and
scope the response type we'll cover when
we look at flows the client ID
identifies that relying party the
redirect URI is where the user should be
sent to afterwards and the server will
check that against a whitelist and the
scope as I said has to at least have
open ID
it's space delimited and then you can
have any other scopes that the relying
party wants to try to request optionally
you can also have a nonce to prevent
replay attacks and the state that gets
transparently passed back on the other
end once the user is authenticated they
redirect back to the relying party might
look something like this you can see
that redirect URI we had there will
appear there and then we're in this case
because we were asking for a code we'll
have a code pass to us and then in this
case because we had some state that will
be passed back transparently that's
basically it so we mentioned MSA before
if you're using Open ID Connect this is
a really really cool place to do it
because you can do essentially anything
you want at this authorization endpoint
between the user getting redirected to
your endpoint and then that getting
redirected back to the relying party so
if you want to use this you use this
time you can also trigger an MFA
challenge at this point before that
redirect happens and that makes it
really really simple to integrate this
stuff so the next endpoint to talk about
is the token endpoint this is an oauth2
compatible endpoint unlike the
authorization endpoint where real users
hit and has a UI this is just a server
server communications so it's basically
just an API endpoint what this will do
is perform authentication of a relying
party the relying party when it hits
this endpoint always has to authenticate
itself and then it will return some
tokens now there's a few different
exchanges that can happen at this
endpoint but the three main ones are it
will either exchange a code for an ID
token access token and auto-refresh
circuit or you can exchange a refresh
token for an access token and a new
refresh token to use next time or you
can exchange some sort of set of
credentials for an ID token and or an
access token and this will make a bit
more sense when we look at the flows
here's an example of what the HTTP
request might look like in this case
we've taken the Refresh token the
example so you'll do a post HTTP POST
you will perform some sort of
authorization to identify yourself as a
relying party in this case we've got
basic authentication so it'll probably
be the client ID along with some sort of
shared secret but there's other
mechanisms that can be used as well like
client certificates the grant type is a
required field that always has to get
passed through in this case it's refresh
token and so the Refresh token grant
type you have to pass the Refresh token
and you can also optionally pass in a
scope if you want to vary the
authorization for this particular access
token that you're generating the
response will look something like this
is just Jason you'll get in this case an
access token and a refresh token pretty
simple
so we've got an even simpler endpoint up
here which is the user info endpoint so
there's a lot of scenarios when you're
building applications where you need to
know exactly who is logged in and what
permissions you have so this user info
endpoint will return the claims that
your particular relying party is
authorized to see so you'll get a subset
basically of claims based on the subset
of scopes that are requested and we've
got those standard claims up here if you
can't have a look at that later those
standard scopes we looked at before
depending on which ones of those that
you have will give a subset
the standard claims that are here and
that's defined in the spec okay so the
last thing to talk about with open ID
connect are the different flows so when
you're choosing a flow there's a few
different things you need to make
decisions on you need to figure out if
you want an interactive or a non
interactive flow so that's basically if
the user involved or is that some kind
of server server communication you need
to figure out if you need a confidential
versus a public relying party a
confidential relying party being as we
said someone who can be or something
that can be trusted with a secret so
some kind of server typically you need
to figure out what credentials are being
used and who should see them exactly and
you need to figure out what types of
tokens do you need do you need a refresh
token for example in this type of
scenario because you don't want a very
long-lived access token being held by a
client okay let's start by looking at
the interactive flows these are the
flows that involve an end user logging
in and that authorization endpoint we
talked about now there's two different
things that determine which flow you
would probably use and there's actually
three flows so we've got the
authorization code flow the implicit
flow and the hybrid flow now it's worth
pointing out not all of these flows are
going to be available in every
implementation of an agonising connect
server that you have the authorization
code flow does not reveal any tokens to
the user agents that the end user is
using so say our web browser or
something like that the tokens are only
existing in the confidential relying
party so they're kept secret that's an
important thing to think about it is
possible to use Refresh tokens with that
flow whereas conversely in the implicit
flow you can't use refresh tokens and
the user agents that the client that
decide that the user is using will see
the tokens and we'll show you a diagram
of that in a second the hybrid flows
basically the combination of the two in
the hybrid flow the user agent can see
the tokens but you can also use refresh
latencies now if you cast your mind back
to when we showed the authorization
endpoint there was one parameter that we
had to pass in that initial redirect
call
whoo come on response time the response
type value determines which flow that
you're using so if the value is code
you're using the authorization code flow
if the value is ID token or a tea token
and token you're using the implicit flow
and if it's a combination then you're
using the hybrid flow so we thought we'd
show you visually what the authorization
code flow looks like basically in this
scenario the confidential relying party
will redirect the user through to the
authorization endpoint on the identity
provider the identity provider will then
redirect the user back with an
authorization code and the confidential
relying party will then check that code
at the token endpoint with the identity
provider in response for in response for
the actual tokens that are being used so
this flow is really really useful in a
number of different scenarios now there
we go do it manually so we've got here
an example of what hte request looks
like it's pretty much exactly the same
as what we showed for the Refresh token
example the relying party needs to
authorize itself in whatever way the
grant type in this case is authorization
underscore code and for that one we
passed through the code parameter and in
return we get the access token the ID
token and if we requested it using that
offline access scope the Refresh token
cool so we're going to show you now what
the implicit flow looks like so they
called two-legged OAuth and in this
particular flow this is exactly the same
as what we just had accepts it and the
relying party doesn't necessarily do the
same thing the authorization endpoint
will in this case return exactly the
same tokens to the user as as in the
previous example you would have needed a
relying party to go get so the user
themselves will own the tokens that are
involved so you can see here that user
still provides proof of identity they
get back the access and the ID tokens
directly and then they just provide that
straight to the relying party in this
case everyone knows about the tokens
there's cases where you might not have a
choice you actually might need to use
this flow
for example in JavaScript applications
that's really common we've got here an
example of what HP request looks like
the important thing to note here is that
you can see the hash in the URL that
basically means that the server doesn't
ever have to see this particular ID
token it's all held purely on the client
so we've got we've got the hybrid flop
here's is the third flow that we want to
talk about the hybrid flow is exactly
the same as the implicit flow but you
also have refresh tokens and you might
need this in certain scenarios or again
you don't want a particularly long lives
access token to be held in this case you
pass an authorization code as well and
you can exchange that as at the relying
party on the identity server in exchange
for a refresh token and then use that
from there cool now that we've looked at
the interactive flows that involve real
users you look at the non interactive
flows these only involve server to
server communications kind of as you'll
see in a second now the first one that
we will look at is something called
client credentials flow so can you say
yeah
so in this flow the relying party will
pass its credentials to the token
endpoint with a grant type of client
credentials and in return it will get an
ID token access token and or refresh
token that identifies that relying party
this is useful for server to server
communications where you want services
calling other services in the background
asynchronously and that kind of thing
the cool thing about this is this means
you can use your identity provider not
only to identify your users but also to
identify all of your servers so you
can't get this added benefit is quite
powerful so the next one is called
resource owner credentials flow so that
ten times now in this flow the relying
party actually takes the credentials
from the user
now we've obviously been talking about
how that's a really bad idea throughout
this presentation but there are some
circumstances in which it's still a
reasonable thing to do so for instance
so you've got Facebook
they've created their own mobile app if
you go and look at it you'll see that
the username and password fields are
part of the native experience is not
popping up a web browser so they're not
using one of the other flows they're
doing something like this the reason for
that is because they want to control the
experience of the app and make it nice
and native and they can do that because
they're the ones that built the app so
they know how the app handles the
password doesn't siphon it off somewhere
or do something dodgy and they obviously
also control the identity provider on
the other side however you think about a
third-party company creating a mobile
app that you get people to log in on
behalf of their Facebook user identity
there's no way Facebook is going to let
you create that kind of experience so in
that case that's where you have to pop
up that web browser and use the other
flows where you're only ever entering
the credentials into the Facebook
website this is an example of what the
client credentials flow looks like from
a HTTP point of view very similar to the
other two examples we showed and really
basic you just pass quite a grant type
of client underscore credentials and
then for the resource owner credentials
flow very similar grant type of password
and then you pass in the username and
the password so
as we said before trying to get our
heads around the open ID connects back
you know it's brain melting it's a very
simple spec but it's still a spec
there's still a lot of little aspects to
it but you don't really need to know it
in real depth as we said you can just
pull in a library so I guess the
takeaway is that we want people to get
from this talk would be you know an
understanding of claims based
authentication knowledge about say JWT
tokens understanding that open ID
Connect is a thing and that you should
use it for authentication rather than or
what - understanding that open OD
Connect has a bunch of different flows
and there's a few just different
decision points to choose which one
that's pretty much all you need to know
because from there you can probably go
and have a glimpse through parts of the
spec it's actually reasonably well
written it's quite simple and sort of
from there figure out okay in this
scenario this is probably what I want to
do so what we're going to try to do is
to just a slight a small sorry demo of
an open OD connect server just to
illustrate a couple of the concepts that
we just talked about so so what we've
got here is on this computer we've
created an identity server at localhost
4 for 399 slash identity and if you
remember from the metadata slide that
Matt talked about what does that mean
ah that's why there's that dot move up
up dot well - known slash open ID -
configuration now some of the things
that we see in here are things like the
issuer we've got the authorization
endpoint the token endpoint the user
info area in point that we talked about
we've got a whole bunch of other things
like they're supported scopes and you've
got things like the supported response
types so these are all these flows we
talked about like I said not all I did
open a connect servers will support all
of the flows this one does if you're
curious this is using identity server 3
on dotnet
really important URI and here is this JW
KSU are I'm there so we click through on
that jwkr stands for a JSON web key
basically a format that allows you to
describe I guess a public certificate in
JSON format so all these values here
represent the public certificate of the
signing certificate that this identity
server uses to sign JWT s so the relying
party that pulls in an open ID can act
library can go and hit this endpoint hit
this particular URL from the endpoint
grab this information and it's got
everything it needs to be able to verify
whether a token is intact as I said
really powerful stuff so what we've got
here is a JavaScript client that's going
to be using implicit off against that
open ID connect server that we had so
we're just going to go to the network
tab here and we're going to click login
cool oops so as you can as we can see
here when it loads type yeah ctrl long
taking ages to refresh some reason as we
can see here we're actually on that
identity server now this is based off
hitting the authorization endpoint we
talked about and we've got a UI here to
put a username and password in now
before we do that if we just go to f12
what they're talking and it again ok
cool here we go
so here's an example Oh existing right
is an example of hitting that
authorization and point maybe just I'm
out because I'm crazy so it's probably
bit hard to see now but we hit that
authorized endpoint we pass through a
state and nonce we pass through a client
ID in this case of JavaScript underscore
implicit we passed a redirect URI which
is HTTP localhost for 21500 slash index
dot HTML and we also passed a response
type of ID tokens with just asking for
an ID token
and we're using the implicit flow and we
also pass through that required scope of
open ID so it's all the stuff that we
were talking about and then this
particular identity server has given us
this login page if we log in got it
wrong dude Jimmy job yeah go for it all
right for that York word if I gotta run
- yeah they're working yeah okay spits
buh
so now we can see we got taken back to
that index.html on localhost 21500 and
we've got the hash test the server would
never have seen this we've got the ID
underscore token barely there and then a
whole bunch of other stuff the Java
scripts basically just showing us the
parameters that were passed here so you
can see we also got the scope and the
stage and stuff like that now that ID
token if we grab that value let me do it
quite long and we go to this brilliant
site called JWT - IO if you want to take
any takeaways from this talk if you're
working with JW T's you remember that
Sykes is awesome you can paste in on the
left hand side and on the right here
it's decoded it for us so on the header
day you can see that type we talked
about we've got the x.509 thumbprint and
then here we've got all of our claims so
we've got that issue of local host four
four three nine nine we've got the
audience which is our client ID we've
got the expiry time in UNIX format the
nonce we had the time it was issued and
the subject so that's the username that
I typed in username one other thing I'd
point out about GWT just scroll up you
pretty much know you're dealing with the
JWT you've got a Y followed by a bunch
of stuff followed by a dot followed by
ey followed by a bunch of stuff I live i
dot for what very munch of stuff so you
pretty much look for UI and then a whole
heap of stuff and you typically go to
JWT the reason why is because the basics
default encoded version of squiggly
brackets followed by a stay on quote is
a way
cool and so we've got here a few
examples of links that you might want to
go have a look at these two links at the
top are a pretty complete list pretty
comprehensive list of all the different
implementations of Open ID connect that
you can go and have a look at you've got
a few different software as-a-service
ones a few different self hosted ones
which are basically off-the-shelf ones
that you'll just set up and go with and
then we've got a few examples at the
bottom identity cerveteri being one of
them of a service that you can set up
and really customize yourself which are
really really useful to have a look at
useful when you want to do like a lot of
custom scopes and claims and
authentication kind of cool stuff like
that cool and that's it thank you thank
you if you want to get this slide you
can go to bit ly / modern or that'll pop
you off to the github where we've got
the slides got any questions so what
would be the keep anything so I don't
really developing that using overriding
correct is there is there a penalty just
going yeah so the question was we've got
an existing site it's done all the
different libraries for Dropbox Google
and Facebook or whatever it is all using
oauth2 rather than open ID connect
should you move across I guess it
depends on whether you trust that all of
those different libraries that you've
pulled in don't have any security holes
right because obviously there's quite a
few so that every single one of those
could have a hole that the others might
not have right to be fair those
companies are pretty big they're
probably pretty robust they've been used
a lot if it's working you probably don't
need to touch it right there like going
forward potentially use something like
this because it's an easier standard
next time you don't have two point five
libraries you just pull in one and
you're good to go right
the JWT one or the summer one oh yeah
yeah that'sthat's little oh and I take
sec so the the slides where we're
showing the flows by the way like the
clicker wasn't working so to get the
full effect is probably better to
download the deck and make sure you look
through because it's a lot easier to
understand when you see it it by bit
yeah
sure yeah good question yeah cool really
good question so the question was in the
self-contained token helps of eternal
time in the self-contained token example
here how can the relying party know that
this token is valid if it's not
communicating directly to the identity
provider the reason being that this this
step here is what the token validation
so the token formats we looked at both
sam'l and JWT both have a component
inside of them with a cryptographic
signature that cryptographic signature
is signed by either a secret key that
you've exchanged previously with the
identity provider or by a public/private
key pair where you know what the public
key is so that JW KS URL that we looked
at for a open OD Connect that the public
key of the certificate is using that it
has a private key for that assigns the
certificate so what you can do is you do
the cryptographic hashing algorithm on
the contents and then you can tell if
the signature is different so the
signature is different the token has
been tampered with
and thus it's not it's not safe to use
right yes so you would know if the key
used to sign the token that's the same
key based on that registration step I
talked about right that might involve
exchanging ass appreciated secret key or
it might involved in the case of open ad
Connect going to that well-known
discovery endpoint pulling out the
public key and then using that key sure
that's that's a fair point but that
would happen like once only or in the
background asynchronously if in the
actual authentication flow this is it it
doesn't need to talk to the identity
provider because it's previously
exchanged information so it knows how to
verify the tokens
yeah absolutely yeah so the question was
and the token you know you don't know
how it's been obtained you just get this
token this is actually the concept
called bearer tokens the bearer tokens
means the person holding it just by the
nature of the fact that they're holding
it you can you just you have to trust it
that makes sense now obviously there's
circumstances where tokens might get
compromised and that's where you do
things like lower the lifetimes of
access tokens and stuff like that so
that if they do get compromised they can
only be used for a certain amount of
time then they're not useful anymore if
that makes sense
so okay so sure yeah so depending on
what protocols you use there may be some
protocols that allow you to use
certificates in a slightly different way
like potentially you present a
certificate at this point and that
somehow gets encoded and token in terms
of Open ID Connect what you're relying
on is that it's always over HTTPS and
you say you trust that the token is it's
very unlikely that the tokens have been
compromised if that makes sense
so the combination of HTTPS combined
with token validation means that you
generally can just trust the tokens any
other questions yes so the question was
to the major identity providers support
this pretty much yeah I don't know top
of my head of Google does but I'd be
damned surprises that aren't Microsoft
definitely do so pretty much yeah so
it's probably all we got time for feel
free to hit us up later and we can
answer any questions thanks guys
[Applause]